Indium is a really fascinating material.
And we're going to show you why it was called indium,
how you can mold things out of it
And how you can do some reactions. And Neil's going to have some rules.
Fun.
Had quite a few samples of indium because it is a slightly
poisonous element and people give it to him rather than having to dispose
of it themselves.
And so he has a selection of pieces of rods and wires,
and a really quite nice thick wire that was originally coiled.
And he showed how you can just pull the coil apart.
And even this thick wire is so bendy that when you put your hands
together, it just bends with almost no effort at all.
Look, Oh my God, who is that?
He still lives in dim wire. It's very, very malleable, very,
very soft.
It's very easy to form into shapes, but what was really nice was the inmate,
the ball of this wire, and then thumped it with a hammer
know,
Neil has a big selection of hammers and produced quite a nice flat
sheet. These pieces of wire,
essentially cold molded together.
And as students I sold the sheet,
I thought we should try and make an impression of a coin.
Um.
So I produced a British 20 Pence piece,
which has a nice picture of her majesty the queen and put it on the India.
[Inaudible].
And Neil hit it with a hammer.
Of course he hit the side with not the Queen's picture on it's out of respect.
And we got a very nice impression of the queen on the second
attempt. It was even nicer
Though. He did bend my coin and it's really remarkable how much
detail can be pressed into this soft metal.
You can even see her earring. I didn't know the queen wore nearing.
I've never looked at her portraits in such detail then because
we have many viewers in the United States,
we felt it was only right to do an impression of an American coin.
So we chose the quarter.
Neil conveniently had one hanging on the wall of his office,
and that also produced an impression.
But not quite beautiful as.
The impression of her majesty,
but then it was time to do slightly more serious experiments.
And one of the things about indium and the reason why I've used it in my career
is that it has really quite a low melting point,
just above 150 degrees centigrade.
And it can be used for soldiering things.
We therefore wanted to demonstrate how easily you can melt it.
So Neil put quite a large amount of India into a polling
tube, heated it up and you can watch it melting.
And then when it melted, he thought it was a pity to waste the liquid metal.
He poured it into little mold and made a sort of hemisphere
of indium.
And what.
See to tout being Neil. He couldn't resist the hammer again.
And so he hammered it again almost flat.
Uh, again, when I.
Was using indium as soda for my research,
I was soldiering gold thermocouples thermocouples for measuring
very low temperature. And I remembered that when I was doing this,
sometimes the gold would melt because the indium
alloyed with the gold and caused it to melt,
which of course ruined the thermocouple.
So I had a small piece of gold thermal, couple wire left.
I found in my cupboard in here and I wanted Neil to
dissolve it in his liquid indium. First of all,
we made the mistake because we forgot that there was varnish on the
wire, but he burnt that off.
And even so we never got it to work.
I don't know whether I was particularly clumsy when I was a student using indium
soda, or we were doing something else wrong, but it was a bit of disappointment.
However, the next experiment was really good.
Many of you may think that the element indium was named after the
country, India I'm here in India, in Mumbai.
What used to be called Bombay behind me is the gateway to India
because there are lots of elements named after countries or States,
California, gallium, germanium, and so on.
But in fact, it turns out that indium was named after a color,
the color Indigo,
which is the sort of violet color that you'd see in rainbows
when Indian was first discovered,
it was discovered actually as a line in the spectrum of violet line
before they had isolated. And if the metal,
so Neil decided that we should try and see this
violet color, this Indigo color. And we tried to Excel.
Experiments.
First one was just take a crucible with India,
minutes to heat in the map to let melted and then put a blow torch
on it. That is a high temperature, gas flame,
and see what you could see.
And there was a really nice Indigo color.
Brady was really excited, unfortunately,
that was just the time that I chose to go out to the room to a meeting. So I.
You got it, baby. You got it.
Actually, they didn't see the color straight away,
but they had to hit the Indian pretty hard. And then the color appeared.
I think the reason is that the color comes from
atoms, not very many atoms in the gas phase.
So you've got to hit the India map to a very high temperature.
And once it is in the gas phase,
it is hot enough for the electrons to be excited in
the atoms.
And then when these electrons return to their original level,
they give out light.
It is a characteristic of indium that because of the
energy levels, that the light comes out at this very characteristic,
violet, Indigo color, which other elements don't produce.
So it was quite easy for the German discovers of the element
to notice that there was something unusual, this unusual line.
Then I suggested that Neil to try desolving indium in bromine,
the reason being that most Indian salts are colorless and
bromine is red. So I thought it would look nicer on the video. It looked nice,
but then Jim didn't dissolve.
So it was a bit of a disappointing experiment. So it was good.
Dave wasn't there,
but Neil is a huge believer in nitric acid to dissolve almost anything
except gold. So he poured,
concentrated nitric acid on the Indian and was not disappointed.
Great.
Babblings bubbles of [inaudible] the Brown gas
and the indium at least partly dissolved.
The indium is dissolving and making indium nitrates.
That's indium three plus irons.
And I know three minus irons.
We never isolated the intimidate trait,
but because I hadn't been there new thoughts,
he would try and show me the color again,
this time he took some wooden splints.
These are just very thin bits of wood and dipped it into the nitric
acid solution,
which now contained indium irons and put
that in the flame.
And you could see the nice Indigo color.
I'd never seen that before. And so it was really quite an exciting first.
Yeah. I still think the purple color of plutonium's three salts and nicer,
but we can't do plutonium in Neil's lab yet.
So India is a good substitute.
Are many other elements named after colors? Um,
well Iridium is named after its many colored
salts, rather like the English word iridescence.
And I believe that rhodium is also named after the red color of one of
its salts.
And I'm sure our viewers will remind me of lots of other elements that are named
after colors, but I can't think of any immediately.
There's a really important use for indium,
which is in almost any sort of computer display screen,
which consists of liquid crystals or some similar
materials sandwiched between two pieces of glass.
Obviously you have to be able to see through the glass so you won't see the
display, but the glass,
the inside surface of the glass has to conduct electricity.
Otherwise you cannot activate the pixels.
So what happens is that the glass is coated with a material called
indium tin oxide.
I sent emails all over the university to try and find sample of glass
with indium tin oxide. And then Neil said,
I've got a big piece. So I need to bother. They could adjust us.
Neil what's you see is there's a sheet of glass,
which has a thin coating of indium tin oxide on one side
and not on the other.
If you take a meter that measures electrical resistance,
you can see that on the glass side,
doesn't conduct electricity at all. But on the other side,
where there's the indium tin oxide,
as you move the probes of the meter apart,
you can see the resistance goes up and down and it does conduct electricity.
Doesn't conduct it terribly well, but it's transparent.
And it does conduct enough for displays.
There is quite a serious problem in terms of
sustainability,
where are the computer screens going to come for your children,
your grandchildren,
because the supplies of indium are beginning to
run out.
So it's really very important that when you finish with your LCD
screen, when you finish with your computer,
your smartphone, you should get it recycled.
So people can begin to reclaim these elements.
Or you may find that when you get to your aid phone 20 or a
phone 30, there won't be enough indium to be put on the screens.
Obviously we try to bring you as much chemistry as possible here in our videos,
but if you really want to fill your boots, why not check out the great courses?
Plus have a look at this
60 half hour lessons with the Georgetown university expert,
all about chemistry. Everything's here. Essentially.
It's guiding you through a full college level chemistry curriculum,
and this is just one of an ever-growing library of courses.
They have covering all sorts of subjects. You name it.
They're going to have no tests, no homework, just lots of knowledge.
You can do them on your computer tablet, phone, whatever for a free trial,
go to the great courses plus.com/periodic videos.
So they know you came from here, should be on the screen,
down in the description,
check them out people and our thanks to them for supporting this video.